اليه عسكريه روسيه مدمره ليست على جبهات
القتال بل في اشهر ميدان في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه جابها لاستعراض ما غنمه الجيش
الاوكراني من الجيش الروسي منذ بدايه
الغزو على اوكرانيا بهذه الطريقه قررت
القياده المدنيه والعسكريه الاحتفال بعيد
الاستقلال لدواعي امنيه مع كل هذا الصره
الاوكرانيون على الحضور لارسال رساله عن
الصمود الى جبهات القتال كنت احضر هذه
الاحتفالات دائما مع ابي من قبل اتذكر
انني عندما كنت طفل لم اكن ارغب في
الاحتفال بعيد الاستقلال لكن الان تغير
موقفي عندما اسير في وسط المدينه ارى ان
العرض لم يعد كما كان وكل هذه المركبات
المدمره لا تمثل سوى اثنين في المئه من
تلك التي تقطر شعبنا
بعيد العالم لذا قرروا المجيئه من اجل غرس
علم على روح كل واحد فقدوه في جبهات
القتال
يتم وضع هذا العلم هنا اذا فقد شخص ما
حياته من اجل اوكرانيا نقدر ذلك جدا ولكن
لابد من ان نتذكر ايضا بانهم رفعوا
العلامه الاوكرانيه في جبهات القتال وهذا
يعني ان هناك من ضحى بحياته من اجل
استقلالنا وشعبنا
يفتخر الاوكرانيون بعيد استقلالهم ولكن في
ظروف خاصه ومميزه جدا لانهم يخافون من
تكرر ضربات الروسيه على العاصمه
يفضلون البقاء بقرب محطات المترو او في
داخلها